right now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week first off
antibiotics can be highly effective when
used to fight bacterial infections but
over prescribing and miss prescribing
the drugs has created a public health
problem this week the American Medical
Association published research analyzing
and comparing the antibiotic prescribing
rates of various medical outlets
including those retail clinics urgent
care centers medical offices and
emergency departments here to go over
this study and more is CBS News medical
contributor dr. tara Narula thank you
for joining us so in comparing these
rates I mean what do we find well we
found something interesting which is
that we tend to think about antibiotic
prescriptions or over-prescription
coming from emergency rooms and medical
offices but actually there's a growing
sector that's often under recognized and
that is urgent care clinics and retail
clinics retail clinics found in
pharmacies and grocery stores urgent
care clinics we know that there's over
10,000 high volume centers in the United
States these are areas where we're
seeing lots of antibiotic prescriptions
being given out and when researchers
really looked at how many times the
antibiotics are being given for sort of
inappropriate respiratory diagnosis it
was most often in urgent care centers it
was three times more often in urgent
care centers than medical offices two
times more often than in emergency rooms
if we know why you know I think a lot of
people go to urgent care centers with
the expectation that they might get a
prescription their primary care doctors
not there who they have a relationship
with who can really tell them you know
what this isn't something that needs it
you can hold off and then there is
something called the yelp effect that
the that has been written about which is
the idea that we live in an environment
of social media where a lot of
businesses and doctors are impacted by
reviews and the last thing that a lot of
businesses want is for somebody to write
a review saying I went I didn't get the
same hack or the antibiotic that I got
that I expected a couple of years ago
Tara the CDC said nearly 30% of all
antibiotic prescriptions were
unnecessary so what sort of public
health problems does that create it can
create a big one we're talking about 80
million prescriptions a year that are
inappropriate of antibiotics and the
situations that can come from this
people can have allergic reactions to
antibody
that they didn't know they had an
allergy to they can kill off good or
healthy bacteria that can lead to
illnesses like c-diff which is a
diarrhea infection that become can
become deadly
it can lead to increased medical costs
increased hospital stays or length of
stay and increased mortality and what
most concerns me is that patients that
are most vulnerable those who need
chemotherapy organ transplant patients
surgical patients burn and trauma
patients may lose a really vital tool of
antibiotics if they if there's
resistance that develops and it's really
that resistance that we worry a lot
about the Washington Post wrote about
this in fact that they said the urgent
care doctors and owners worry about what
their what this yelp effect and if
doctors when when they see patients who
mentioned this early and I think what we
need to do is really set expectations
and that's why stuff like this is
important in terms of educating people
that not every time you go do you need
an antibiotic and there need to be that
open line of communication with the
doctor and also the doctor can take time
to really educate on what else you can
use besides antibiotic to make you feel
better alright our next topic the rising
rates of heart attack during pregnancy
research published by the Mayo Clinic
looked at us hospital data from 2002 to
2014 their analysis found that for women
hospitalized during and soon after
pregnancy heart attacks occurred in
roughly one out of every 12 thousand
cases with the rates actually increasing
over that period why have they been
going up - well it's interesting one of
the things is that we're seeing more
women have babies at advanced maternal
age and we know that that increased age
can increase your risk for heart attack
in addition there's been changing
cardiovascular risk profiles over the
last 10 or 15 years we're seeing more
hypertension diabetes obesity we now
have better testing more sensitive blood
tests that can pick up on heart attacks
and we're probably testing people more
frequently so that may be one of the
reasons why we're diagnosing it more
often and there's more provider
awareness we are more aware now that
this can happen so we may be looking for
it a little bit more were these certain
factors did it make some women more at
risk
so certainly advanced maternal age if
you had pre-existing cardiovascular
disease or if you had risk factors like
hypertension diabetes tobacco or drug
abuse anemia or even [ __ ]
to your cancers but one important thing
to remember is that pregnancy in and of
itself is really a state of increased
risk for anyone you have hormonal
changes hemodynamic changes in your
cardiac output and your blood volume and
also it your it's a time where you're
more prone to clotting so all of this
really increases the stress we call it a
stress test really on the body all right
finally could playing video games
actually help kids lose weight a setting
led by researchers at Louisiana State
University assigned 46 overweight
children to a program of exergaming or
to a controlled group extra gaming is
the term for video games that demand
physical movements of the body after 24
weeks they found that kids in the extra
gaming group had improved BMI scores and
improved cardio health the authors say
exergaming combined with other
activities could be seen as a viable way
to lose weight the only exercise my son
at least when he's gaming is yelling no
I mean you know we know that a lot of
our six to eleven year olds are obese
and they have early signs of
cardiovascular disease so more and more
we're understanding that bringing
technology to people whether it's with
fitness trackers telehealth or gaming
even though it sounds different for what
we're used to can be important ways to
kind of improve fitness yeah always what
goes in the mouth is the key weight loss
yes dr. Tara Narula thank you so much